before we even made it out to to
Northeast Thailand which is where we
piloted the lessons we did a little
market research in Bangkok not far from
the headquarters of PDA we walked with a
translator up and down the streets and
sort of talk to whatever small business
owners were willing to talk to us so we
talked to a fruit stand owner we talked
to a coffee stand owner and one of the
people we talked to owned a barber shop
we helped and he said oh you know the
first thing he said was oh you're trying
to help people great I really want to
help you guys but more to the point of
business sophistication you know we
asked it we immersed we were talking
about his business and he was you know
sort of very carefully articulating you
know what he did and how much he made
and very forthcoming with information
and the minute we asked him about you
know any sort of detail about the
numbers what he earned he he sort of
turned around and he reached into a
drawer and he pulled out these these
books these record books that not only
had all of the numbers written out but
as he turned the page that he had charts
of you know he had charts and graphs and
sort of he had very clear he had very
carefully plotted his his income over
time and his profit over time and oh
well the month of you know for one month
a year that I celebrate the new year and
everybody leaves Bangkok nobody gets a
haircut his revenue goes down and you
can very clearly see that on his charts
and for him I mean I understand that
I've been through more education than
I'd like to admit but he hasn't and he
could articulate the same thing to me
because somebody has taught him to do
that and I think sort of understanding
that he can do that means that other
people can do that and it was it was
very heartening in terms of knowing what
it was that we would and wouldn't have
to teach